instead of having people uh on on the
ground
you're gonna have uh uh you know a site
in tel aviv and every floor is gonna be
a different site
and they're remotely managing the drones
and robots and
and crawlers and and boats and
submarines like everything is autonomous
and collects that information
so that's that's the collection part
that's that that's the
you know that's the cool version like
everybody looks at the drone itself and
it flies around it's fun but
but the value part is actually in the
reporting in the ai
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders we have with
us ariella vitan the co-founder and
chief commercial officer of percepto
ariel is a big data expert with two
decades of experience leading and
facilitating team growth in the dynamic
startup world
as a founder of percepto he leads the
commercial front
leveraging his deep market understanding
and diverse skill set to drive long-term
company growth
prior to co-founding percepto arielle
was a founding member and vp marketing
of sequoia backed signals
and head of information security at
frost and solvent europe
ariel vitan thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good thank you thank you for having
me thank you for joining me this morning
uh talking all about you know autonomous
vehicles
gathering data specifically drones a
chief commercial officer of percepto
but you have had quite a few hats as vp
marketing and account management at
signals a sequoia-based company and
you were an analyst and studied in ben
gurion university and and
all around you know you can see the
entrepreneurial trail
climbing up and and and what i'm excited
to hear about is you know the different
insights that you've had throughout your
journey
talking specifically about you know
percepto today and and how
our autonomous vehicles playing an
integral part of our future
of understanding you know the world
around us and
and what is the what is the proper way
to to think through them
strategically so so i there's a lot of
things that i'm excited to talk about
but we have to go back to your
young days of playing tennis because
that's really the most important part
so you were a tennis player as a kid
yeah i was uh it was really a long time
ago when i was uh
around 11 12 uh played a lot of tennis i
actually came
came to do this back uh uh right now
doing uh you know
once a week on of courses uh not gonna
be ranked anymore
unfortunately but uh i think i think it
has to do a lot uh
you know tennis is a as an individual
game gives you a lot uh
you know a lot a lot of character uh and
a lot of uh
uh ways to overcome uh you know
individual uh
challenges as opposed to a group game
right
so uh i think a lot from it uh i love it
uh
it it brings me into like to my maximum
in terms of the uh
ability to play in uh mentally and and
physically so uh yeah
it's a good it's a good game to have i
remember i
used to compete in high school with my
with my high school team and i remember
that
i was always standing with the coach
during the games in the tournaments and
he would always
and you know every you know to every 15
minutes or so he would come and say
he's got a double fault and i remember
that he had this look in his eye that he
was able to capture that moment
when he saw the player that was playing
singles or doubles you know that
that action and i was always fascinated
by this this action of serving
which is you know innately it's the same
action that you always do there
shouldn't be any external forces other
than wind
yet sometimes you know people double
fault even even federer sometimes double
faults
and i was always fascinated by the
mental strength you need
to be a good tennis player and and i
have so much respect
for that mental strength arielle walk me
a little bit through your journey
through the different companies and
we'll end up in in percepto to talk
about you know the world of drones
so my professional life i started in uh
in uh sayora
which is a information security uh uh
company best known for uh uh for uh
naftali bennett being the
ceo of the company
i started there as a business analyst
and i grew there from business analyst
to product
specialist and then product manager i
learned a lot there
uh you know the great guys that work
with me there it's a very
unique set of team you can see them in
all the leading companies today in the
world
uh especially in the israeli tech
and uh just you know good professional
people
that talk uh very straight to the point
very realistic
and and uh i think i got a lot from that
you know from that baseline as
a teaching uh uh experiment for me
after that i moved into uh completely
other uh
segment uh i remember my conversations
with a headhunter
uh asking you know i wanna i wanna start
uh flying around the world and doing a
lot of uh
uh more uh business oriented work and uh
she gave me a
head of information security practice
and in our consulting company
which is a whole different you know bowl
game it's not even close to being a
product manager and
startup and it gave me so much to see
you know
smaller startups uh in in the world
seeing the different cultures
and how they grow startup uh what's
their motivation where they're lacking
in terms of you know
uh the the startup ecosystem in in
israel
and it gave me a lot of perspective and
a lot of good uh
experience uh finished there managing
around uh 10 different uh individuals
globally wow
um and uh what is one
what is one main thing that you learned
from that experience that somebody who
wouldn't go through that experience or
doesn't have the ability to go through
that experience would
would gather from you so i'm trying to
you know what i love doing is extracting
these like you know
overarching ideas from somebody who had
a lot of experience
when i still didn't have that experience
i think that the biggest thing that i
learned there is that there
that the uh
the culture of where you build the
business
affects your business tremendously like
without even
understanding right there is a base
culture in israel for pushing forward
and moving things along not
even if you don't have the back the
backbone and there's a very different
culture in
in startups in spain or uh in in poland
or in the uk or in the us
where you know people have to have that
you know
technical kind of uh uh
baseline or to move forward and they're
moving forward slower they're taking
step by step that's why you know we're
very fast and moving
wide you know quite fast on on building
the startup but then we have to
close the gaps while startups in the us
usually don't have that big of a gap
because they're doing things much more
gradual but they're slower and in in
moving forward just
a little taste that culture makes
everything like uh
uh defines your your your company and
and how it will right now that makes all
the sense okay so you're finished with
that experience
managing the 10 people what's happening
what happens next
so i met
i met the the co-founders of
of then uh dna visual insights which are
later on be signals
uh very good friends and then uh we
i joined them as the vp of marketing uh
really early on there were like five six
seven people
uh and there you know the the idea was
to take a lot of external data and
convert that into
meaningful insights for big
organizations so just as an example
if uh johnson johnson or procter gamble
they're doing the next
product or toothpaste or you know jordan
whatever
they need to have data that has to do
with you know what is not working with
their current product and how they make
uh the best today most of the uh work or
not today but uh you know five
six years ago most of the work were uh
uh were
control groups right you bring 30 people
you tell them they ask them
whatever and then whatever they hear
from there and there what we did is
create a whole sense of external data
that has to do with uh
you know from patents and publications
on the academy side to
voice uh voice uncharted voice and
on the net to give a much broader
understanding of where the product is
supposed to go
uh very very interesting path we grew to
around 100 people like you said we're
back by uh
sequoyah and then later on uh kumra
and more and more uh to come uh
great experiences uh really worked
really learned how to work with large
core corporates and i think that's
something that is missing
a lot in in israel how to work with you
know
heavy heavy b2b uh uh
b2b uh clients um and you know israel is
very
good about b2c or small b2bs but when
you need to talk to a vp
at a g in a gm or a vp and johnson
johnson
it's a whole different level of
conversations to get to where you want
to go
and that that was a great learning curve
and experience and also the experience
of
building teams how do you build a team
that can execute
right and move forward and broad growing
a company is uh you know is a master of
its own
uh which i was fortunate to have to
learn uh uh at sydney
so what what are some things that
surprised you in
this new world of of talking to vps that
at these no fortune fortune 100 fortune
500 companies
um you know in the vp positions what are
you
what did you learn along the way that
you're like oh interesting okay i didn't
i didn't realize it works quite like
this this is something that would
probably have been useful to me and to
many others that are
starting their journey yeah i'll
sidetrack and come back i mentor at the
uh
uh at the zell program in the idc uh
and you know they use a lot of uh
when they come in with their they were
their ideas a lot of them are you know
apps and
whatever things that are very easy to uh
technically right but you know they go
to btc's
small business and and i love
heavyweight like i think that you know
if you want to make a big impact you
want to push into uh
uh into the uh large companies and make
sure that they can
uh you know change something big on
their end because
their effect is you know something that
affects
thousands hundreds of thousands you know
millions of people
and uh what i learned a lot is is the
the you know the sales cycle and the
cycles in general in these big companies
you can have a bp loving your product
you know
but for him to move forward right it's
almost
uh it's almost uh uh the anti-startup uh
uh you know kind of uh typecast of a
client like
you want to go forward and we see this
in preceptor as well
everybody is positive everybody wants to
but the you know that that wheel is so
so slow and uh as opposed to getting you
know frustrated from it when you come
into startup when i came from signals
into percepto
you know this is this is a very big chip
to know because then you plan the
company
because you know the cycles are are
longer but what enables you to
what do you now prepare as you approach
this new company what what
first steps do you take to say oh i know
that in a 50 steps we're going to reach
this problem unless we shift our you
know our
we shift our mindset all the way at the
foundation so
what is that shift that you're talking
about here
i think that the shift is is you know
the pre-planning needs to first of all
come with the idea
of uh of planting this this kind of
cycle
the longer cycle in everybody's head
it's the investors
that cannot you know you can't see an
mrr they can't see like every month like
a growing with uh growing a grain chain
when you look at you know large
conglomerates you're looking a year
ahead you know even 18 months ahead
but you have to you know set the
expectations to make sure that
everybody's aligned with it
same goes for uh for sales people same
goes for product people
same goes for uh for management people
need to know that the
cycles are longer but it's okay if you
see the progress you need to measure
yourself
on different elements and not only you
know the spikes that you're
you're you're meeting when you have a
b2c or a light b2b uh solution
so it's like setting expectations all
around right to make sure
that people understand yeah that the
company is growing but it's not
the growth you know as an investor that
invests in a b2c company
it's a it's a it's a heavy b2b company
you have to understand that you have to
make that switch
and i'm guessing that one of the other
key differences is that you know we're
used to in our culture at least i'm used
to
you know sitting with friends in the
coffee shop and talking about our ideas
and then shaking hands and
in israel yeah okay now let's get
started the next day we have some
we have some partnership on the ground
but i'm guessing that in your role
both in both in your previous company
but also in percepto
it's much slower you have to really walk
them hand in hand
and you really have to you know to to
treat that as a long-term relationship
that could take months until it reaches
fruition
and until something actually meaningful
happens in in actual work collaboration
right i mean that must be frustrating
sometimes
i i think again that when you grow up uh
uh into the heavyweight roles like you
the frustration is not it's not it's not
the word like you're you're that's the
reality you're
the yeah this is where we were living
right this is how we how we work and i
think that
you hit a very good point is that no
matter
where he is in the rank like the vp or c
level or director and these big
companies
they're still the guys who need you to
support them from a to z
and uh uh and and i think that
you know people think that we we sell a
product we don't like
i sell a product but companies look for
the overalls the big companies look for
overall services
you want to make sure that you're there
when something goes wrong because as a
champion
they want to make sure that they always
look good right they've always looked it
so we have to be there 24 7 we have to
make sure that uh uh how do we how can
we uh
uh support them and percepto you know
in in my mind and in the mind of
of my teams clients are number one
uh number one uh interest in in the in
the company
we cannot have clients not happy even if
it costs us and it's fine
because these clients grow and they they
uh
they depend on you right to bring the
right solution and innovative solutions
they can take over and then you know
recommend it to their other products or
other uh
other uh sites so they can use it as
well
so uh our clients is everything and
making sure that they
get value that's that's you know the
baseline they need to get value
they need to be you need to be in a
positive attitude to make sure that that
the value is also portrayed because you
can be you know i always
uh say that you can go to an amazing
restaurant you'll never go there again
because the service wasn't good
right you can go to an okay restaurant
and you'll go there every time because
the service is amazing
right it's that link between the
both product and service right i think
that what we're missing out
sometimes on you know the techcrunch
articles and
and the media is that it's it's all
about the people it's all about the
relationships like yes
sure the companies are getting value
from each other and there is a
transaction that is involved
at the end of the day it's you know a
few people that are you know
making a solid relationship with a lot
of trust
and and i and i can see that also you
know
understanding the industry a little bit
better and and i just love that idea
that at the end it is about that trust
and you can't go around
that but arielle i want to hear a little
bit more about percepto
you're working on one of the things that
i'm most excited about you're working on
on autonomous vehicles and how drones
can and can
help you know exponentially increment
the way that we understand the world
around us with with collecting data so
tell me a little bit about percepto and
and that will fall nicely in place
because at percepto also you're in
charge of a lot of these relationships
that we were just talking about
yeah so uh uh preceptor is a company
that deals started as uh
as a as an ai company for uh machine
vision
uh we wanted to create autonomous uh dji
jobs
uh and then we moved uh to from from
relying on dji's to actually creating
our own system for heavy industrial
sites
so it's one of the first uh drones that
are ruggedized and you can put it on on
site and it has a base station and that
that enables an autonomous uh loop so
joan flies around collects data does
whatever it needs to do comes back
charges and then goes to another mission
without needing someone on
on the ground and uh uh you know
fast forwarding we're now a hundred
people we're the most deployed during
the box system in the world
we have systems uh you know for in 10
different countries
and um what we learned from the last two
years
is that there's a bigger stream above us
and that biggest stream
is remote operations so you know think
about five seven years from now
you're gonna have power plants and you
know oil and gas
refineries and uh and mining companies
that are gonna have
you know ten people in instead of three
thousand
because robots are gonna do everything
and we have some examples of companies
already taking that step they have you
know think
like the equivalent is think about the
israeli uh electricity company
instead of having people uh on on the
ground
you're going to have a you know a site
in tel aviv and every floor is going to
be a different site
and they're remotely managing the drones
and robots and
and crawlers and and boats and
submarines like
everything is autonomous and collects
that information
so that's that's the collection part
that's that that's the
you know that's the cool version like
everybody looks at the drone itself and
it flies around it's fun but
but the value part is actually in the
reporting in the ai
so very deep ai technology that enables
to look at anomaly detection change
detection
alerting you know leaks fires whatever
all of that comes together to reduce the
overall cost
of maintaining a site like this reduce
the risk to people on site because these
are
uh hazardous locations and increase the
efficiency
of these sites and that's what we do
today uh so we moved that transition
from drawing a box to uh remotely
operating
uh uh robots in order to convert that
into
meaningful instruments right and i think
that you know
this is something that while it's
incredible and it's you know
i i it's undeniably the world it's so
much undeniably
the future because you know we see it in
cartoons all the way from 1950s
that you know people are expecting this
to be our future right
i mean the idea of robots you know doing
these hazardous tasks in these you know
unsafe environments that's not a new
thing what is new is that it's actually
happening in reality and there's a
there it's actually happening in our
world but what i really want to ask you
i realize
why is this the best time for this why
is it not
you know 10 years ago or in 10 years
why why you know you that you're we've
been working this for more than five
years
we're 20 21 now why is now the best time
for you guys to
to run this company
so i think that that the answer
is is derived there's first of all the
fact that uh
you can only do uh what we're doing
when robotics gets to a place where it's
cheap enough to use
right and the technology there is is
ripe enough to start using it
on a commercial base like we can see a
lot of you know
drones from uh or companies that create
robots from
19 i don't know 1990 or whatever
but it's not a commercialized system and
it costs millions right
when you go into the lower numbers now
it makes sense to use it
and i think that companies we talked
about you know the cycles the companies
go
companies need to this is a
transformation right these are you can
see more and more for example big
companies
their innovation center is becoming from
you know a small group of 10 people
to a a business unit as part of the
business unit
because they need to you know increase
their ability to transform and change
they understand what's going on and they
need to do that
shift and we're riding on that shift as
far as an enabler
right to make that happen and i think
that the time is not
it's not now like that it's going to
happen in the couple of years but you
have to create the system now the
technology in order for them to adopt it
when they're ready to adapt
no that makes a lot of sense and i
really think that one of the things that
you're working on that i'm
i'm most excited about this is you know
breaking breaking the laws of physics as
we know them in society
you know not necessarily literally the
laws of physics but
but the laws of how the world operates
and and whose responsibilities to do
what and
you know we have the social conduct for
thousands of years you know all the way
dating back to the great wall of china
that us humans sometimes we sacrifice
our health or
or our or our you know environment
because for compensation or
in order because something needs to get
done somebody needs to do the job and i
think that
you know in 2021 seeing what you guys
are doing with percepto and you and your
thought process behind it
and and i encourage everybody to go take
a look because it's just awesome to see
and i can't wait to
one day see an actual site in place
maybe you'll invite me even to
a small tour because it's it's just so
so cool and
and i just love it your thing again
thank you
very very much thank you
i would be honored thank you for coming
i have one more important question to
ask it's the hardest one
but i need three words that you would
use to describe yourself
um i think uh
uh realist
very i'll try to be very down to earth
and to understand what's really going on
optimist i have to be an optimist if not
like you know i'll go work in a
conglomerate
and uh um
uh down to earth trying try not
uh you know not to get affected from the
from the uh tech crunches and then
startup uh
see at the end we need to do work and we
need to provide value so i think that
these are we need to work and we need to
provide value
arielle thank you very very much
best of luck with everything continue
making a positive impact
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
okay thank you have a good day